the next story is a video that I can't
play because Ethan Klein said something
that I'm surprised he didn't get banned
over which I'm not going to be able to
play but I can basically tell you what
he said
left-wing YouTube Star Ethan Klein Muse
is about another Holocaust against the
Jews and says he hopes Ben Shapiro is
killed first
yeah it's crazy what show is this on
it's his show H3 TV and they cut the
feed well that's his producers because
he's done stuff like this before where
he's gotten suspended and banned for it
strikes yeah so uh I'll without playing
what he says to verbatim because look I
think we'd get a strike for if I think
if we played with Ethan Klein said
YouTube would strike us right you
probably play up right to the point
where they cut right there but look I
can do this I can move it forward he
starts saying it his own producer then
yeah technical difficulties please stand
by because there was another point where
he called for an act of Terror on
Republicans right out like I'm not
exaggerating he literally said people
should you know go come in an active
Terror and then he's like okay it got a
little carried away there they bring it
back and then apparently after they
bring it back he just keeps talking he
just says it again he says it again yeah
clarifies yeah so he was intimating that
if there was another Holocaust Ben
should be he hopes he said he hopes
hopes now that's something we were
saying before the show if him and Ben
and a few other friends they were all
friends hanging out in their room
playing cards or whatever and then he
said it as a joke and they all laughed
about like Ben's the guy that she get
and there was like haha but you go on TV
when the guy's not even there to defend
him so that's a crazy thing to say right
yeah yeah and he's also called for acts
of Terror against
Republicans that's so weird is that
funny dude these people are dangerous
and insane seriously I like I'm I'm well
past caring about their opinions it's
been years they there are so many people
who try to play this middle of the road
thing where they're like well you know
let's hear what they have to say I'm
like dude called for a terror attack on
a on a convention he's now saying he
hopes Ben gets gassed first these people
are nuts and this is I don't know if
he's going to get banned over this he
won't I doubt it well he did get a
strike from the from the terror attack
one yeah I mean that one was a direct
call to violence this I guess would be a
little more indirect
I don't think he should get a strike my
point on this is basically just that the
rules are in place because of people
like him and other leftists So based on
what they expect they should they should
get a strike based on their own
principles and own rules but you know
they don't have this their morality is
whoever can have the most whoever can
accrue the most power it's fascistic the
late David Graber said that an element
to the left has adopted the fascistic
tenant of tenant of there is no truth
but power and that's clearly on display
with people like him when he got a
strike for calling for an act of Terror
he acted like he was outraged oh hello
are you kidding dude even I think that
should have been a strike you know I'm
all about Free Speech but if you tell
your audience to go and do murders yeah
I think they should at least at the very
least be like hey we're taking that
episode down you shouldn't do that
well there you go this is modern
politics for you where does this where
does where does this where does where
does this standard bring us I err on the
side of free speech for sure and I don't
want the feds being like Oh we gotta we
gotta just cause now to go take this guy
and and unperson him I don't like that
stuff man I'd rather just work it out
with Ethan like he's stressed out he's
saying dumb dumb stuff on the internet
and I'd rather work it out than cause
more of it
with someone like that sorry I I can't
believe I'm saying I kind of agree with
you if people want to be ridiculous
sensationalistic bombastic and idiot I
think let them and and let people know
exactly where they stand but I think the
problem is is that you know he gets to
do this he gets to get get away with
this he gets to hang out with Susan
wojinski someone on the other political
Spectrum or someone questioning the
establishment sneezes the wrong way
automatically uh downranked in the
algorithm demonetized uh screwed over
shut down deleted and censored in many
instances for just expressing political
thought and ideas not calling for
violence not calling for anyone to be
thrown in the chambers and and and
there's there's an unfair balance here
which I think is the critique here that
is fair to make here but the end of the
day I stand with you let people say
whatever ridiculous crazy stuff that
they want and let's let's let us know
where people are really coming from this
is where he's coming from
um and it's important to know agree or
disagree so we the conversation should
happen I do agree and I think his
opinion is not a call to violence it's
an expression of a desire for genocide
um and The prominent individual to be
killed and so I think that's horrifying
I think with his point he's trying to
make is
I'd be willing to bet
because I'm going to give him at least
as much the full context is something
like the right is anti-Semitic Kanye
West and that's why it comes up and then
he probably said yeah well you know what
if it happens it's because of them so I
hope that's what I think the context
probably is I ultimately don't care it's
an insane thing to say I hope Ethan
Klein lives a long and healthy and happy
life I say that about people I don't
like all the time I say look you know I
don't like what they do but I wish them
the best I would have a happy healthy
life and we find a way to live together
peacefully here's the issue no one is
going to come after him he's not going
to get censored the rules don't apply to
him he's going to get away with it his
followers are going to laugh and enjoy
it you get people like Hassan he's a
socialist then he buys a multi-million
dollar property he advocates for
policies to destroy the working class
and and the middle class and then he
uses that wealth to buy fanciful and and
and grandiose things they they are both
part of a faction that advocate for
sensors but people they don't like and
they get away with it now in the end
even if they come out like we're being
edgy you're making jokes and we agree
they should be allowed to the problem is
these people would laugh when you got
banned and we here today are defending
their right to free speech and they do
as someone who has dealt with a lot of
censorship and banned from companies
um I'm well aware that yes this it
pleases the other side when they see it
and again we get banned for sneezing or
the reality is we get banned for things
and they refuse to tell you what you did
right because they don't want to put
that in writing that happened to us
recently I want to point out to Pete
company people are mentioning this too
no Ethan Klein is Jewish right yes yes
yeah yeah him saying this I that's I
understand the point he's trying to make
but it's just like such a disgusting and
violent insane thing to say I'm just
crazy you know like you know more look I
think he and all the other uh uh
Psychopaths should be allowed to express
this so we know who the crazy people are
my point here is just the double
standard we would have when I was
administrating at mines we would have
these weird situations every once in a
while come up where like someone and it
didn't happen much and it didn't happen
to a point where I I felt really bad
about it but like a really popular
person on the website would do something
that violated the terms of service or
that I thought was like whoa this is
coming close and I'm like what do I do
do I ban our cash cow because the reason
mines is solvent right now is because we
have a lot of views the reason we have a
lot of views is because of our popular
video makers do I ban the one the
biggest Cash Cow and it's like if I
don't then I'm letting fascism take over
I'm like the money and the corporation
take my morals and ethics away
um and if I do then the company goes
under what is what are my my two choices
here yeah that's a weird position to be
in as an administrator when I said
people were censored for sneezing the
wrong way I wasn't kidding as you were
mentioning Seth people people got
censored people got banned people got
their whole livelihoods deleted because
of vague terms and services that were
just there and then people were like
wait what exactly did you did you
destroy my livelihood for no we're not
going to tell you we just have these
vague roles with these over
generalizations and we're gonna punish
you because you expressed political
thoughts that we don't like and and it's
not like they even give you any kind of
ability to redeem yourself it's not like
they give you any kind of ability to to
fix your problem no but but we have this
on the other spectrum and again I used
to watch Ethan Klein many years ago he
was interesting he was creative he
actually did content that was engaging
and I don't know what happened to the
guy but it's it's sad to kind of see
this because this could also be an
attempt to try to get attention to try
to say say something shocking so more
people pay attention to you we are
talking about him right now but I think
he has strayed off a long way from where
he was before where he actually uh was
enjoying this he definitely doesn't look
like he's enjoying this he you know I I
wish the guy luck I wish he could you
know get in shape
I'll tell you I'll tell you what it is I
think it's simple it's not it's not good
watching this politics is pop culture
for somebody like me my whole life has
been politics when I was a little kid
um you know I work with my family's
business it was on North Halsted it was
Boys Town in Chicago so all of a sudden
I'm hearing all about these issues with
LGBT pride and stuff like that I start
listening to punk music all the lyrics
are about war and politics and all of a
sudden I'm on the internet I've been in
the internet my whole life I'm a little
kid and I'm seeing all of this news just
inundated with it I work for non-profits
I do fundraising it's all activism I
eventually start covering protests on
the ground my whole life is politics
that leads us to where we are right now
talking about issues that I've talked
about my entire life having me be able
to be able to remember weird things from
back in the early 2000s when most people
weren't paying attention to politics at
all Ethan Klein was a comedy edgy
YouTuber yeah and then at some point pop
culture turned into politics which was
huge for us all of a sudden me I just
talk about politics all the time
getting a bunch more viewers rivaling
some of the biggest entertainment
podcasts even Joe Rogan is now a largely
political show even though he's a
comedian Ethan Klein needs to adapt he
needs to start adopting politics
otherwise he's becoming stale and not
current right the news Trump Trump trump
that's all it was so it happened to
everyone it's not just him now
he has on Jordan Peterson on his Jordan
Peterson on his show yeah what happens
for the most part it's fine but over
time he starts feeling the heat because
his fan base was mixed politically
because it was edgy comedy and now his
time's changing a large portion of his
of his base probably skewing younger
they start getting angrier and more
self-righteous so he deletes the Jordan
Peterson episodes he apologizes that it
was wrong makes no sense yeah and now
he's like if I'm going to be relevant we
have stock politics and thus Ethan Klein
who knows almost nothing about politics
is having a conversation with Ben
Shapiro who has been a political
commentator for decades and has a law
degree
there's clearly a problem here with
politics becoming pop culture someone
who has no idea what's going on saying
they hope someone who is overtly
political gets killed first in a new
Holocaust is just absolutely insane but
he's entitled to his opinion he's
entitled to try and make his show
political and it's clear that he just
went meh modern leftists woke whatever
it's the easy route when you don't
really know what's going on it's simple
you believe jussie Smollett which most
of these leftists do you believe Ukraine
gate you believe Russia gate you believe
Trayvon the hands up don't shoot you
Covington Catholic I love make saying
the list over and over again Bobo
Wallace the garage Paul wrote they love
believing this stuff because they are
low information individuals but they're
also extremely dangerous violent and
angry people they want you to just just
fit in the crowd is doing it why won't
you everyone is saying this is the truth
why won't you well because there is a
truth I don't care what you think it is
two plus two equals four not five shut
up I kind of will double down that I
think
there's there's a saying with great
power comes great responsibility and
with 10 million followers that's a sense
that's a form of great power and so the
things you would say with your friends
in your bedroom or in your living room
when you're playing you know Super
Nintendo or whatever the hell uh insults
dirty jokes you don't say that to 10
million people on TV because you have a
greater responsibility not to be
derogatory I know you want to because
it's natural it's who you were in the
past Ethan particularly probably
probably like me would joke you know
insult your friends as comedy but like
this is taken on another level brother
I don't like to talk about other
commenters you know we I mentioned this
from time to time like I don't know The
Young Turks talks about me all the time
but they'll talk about me saying
something like banal like you know I
think some women might be unhappy
because they want to have families and
then they make this big segment about
temples of sexist then I'm like oh come
on dude calm down I was reading the
Washington Post this is a high profile
podcast which gets tens of millions of
views saying I hope Ben I don't even
want to read it I mean it's just like
come on dude that's crazy there's also
kind of the Britney Spears effect when
it comes to online influencers and a lot
of celebrities who take themselves too
seriously I'm not saying that that's
what's happening with Ethan Klein but
there is uh you know a lot of people who
are in the digital space who are
influenced by the Bots by the comments
and by the people a part of this and you
do see detrimental mental health effects
to this is this maybe potentially one of
the examples here I don't know but but
this is Art unhinged very emotionally
kind of very emotional language that I
don't think the average person is going
to believe me with yeah he's probably
the gentlemen crack your beers now
because I'm going to say it Civil War
this is the kind of stuff that I talk
about this this is I mean look when
Security Experts say we fear it's coming
when uh Princeton professors former CIA
when they're all like we think we're in
the beginning stages of a Civil War and
then a guy who used to make comedy
videos where he would push out his fupa
and pull his chin down and then run
around his house as a gag is now saying
that he he hopes Ben Shapiro is guest
I'm just like yep listen do you see the
radicalization over the past 10 years do
you see why I might think right into
that place Ethan Klein for no reason
there is no reason why he an edgy
YouTube comedy YouTuber should be saying
anything about Ben Shapiro or holocausts
or politics but this is what's happened
with the radicalization in this country
that's why I'm like
that's why I think we're going to we're
heading towards the Civil War or we're
in a cold Civil War whatever you want to
call it when comedy edgy boys turn into
advocates for and like let me just
stress they tried stopping him and then
he was like no no then he said it anyway
yeah like when you get to that point
maybe everything's about to break apart
well I it's I agree that it's like a
radical a form of radicalization what's
happening is the society is very
stressful for a lot of people right now
with inflation with Ukraine with all
this crazy stuff going on if you don't
know the specifics if you don't
understand that Hunter Biden was
involved with barisma for instance that
Biden's had you might just look at it
and be freaking out and then lashing out
which is what Ethan's doing like he's
obviously stressed about Society like we
are but we study the intricate details
about geopolitics so it's I'm not
getting radicalized like if I didn't
understand what was going on I'd be
freaking out screaming at people lashing
out and um I think if he I wanna I wanna
I want you to be more educated he may be
less radical work great work thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there